Nous avions, ça fait déjà, je crois, deux dimanches sur la série où nous avons abordé le chapitre 6.
Et donc la dernière fois, nous nous étions focalisés sur les versets 8 au verset 10.
Et donc là, on a lu, c'était pour rappeler le contexte, mais nous allons plutôt nous concentrer sur les versets 8 à 10,
et même finir plutôt les versets 9 à 10.
La dernière fois, nous avions fait cela.
Donc dernièrement, nous avions commencé à aborder les premiers points de ce passage,
donc quand je parle des versets 8 à 10.
Et nous avions rappelé qu'après des siècles de désobéissance, Dieu apportait un jugement sur Israël.
Donc il avait déjà apporté le jugement sur le royaume d'Israël, le royaume du nord d'Israël,
qui avait été détruit par les Assyriens.
Et maintenant, il était en train d'apporter le jugement sur le royaume du sud, le royaume de Juda,
qui était en train d'être attaqué par les Babyloniens.
Donc après des siècles de désobéissance, Dieu apportait un jugement qui témoignait de sa sainteté,
mais aussi de sa miséricorde.
Pourquoi ce jugement témoignait de la sainteté de Dieu ?
C'est parce qu'Israël s'était souillé par les idoles qu'ils avaient adorées.
Ils avaient violé le commandement qui était au cœur de l'alliance que Dieu avait établie avec eux sept siècles avant.
Et ce commandement est dans Deutéronome 6, 5,
où ils se devaient d'aimer Dieu de tout leur cœur, de toute leur âme, leur force, leur pensée.
Et à cause du fait qu'ils n'avaient pas respecté ce commandement qui était central,
et d'ailleurs nous avions vu pourquoi ce commandement était central,
donc à cause de ce commandement central qu'ils n'avaient pas respecté,
Dieu qui est saint, et qui avait vu Israël se souiller, avait donc apporté le jugement.
Pourquoi ce jugement témoignait de la miséricorde de Dieu ?
C'est que malgré la violence du jugement,
donc vous avez pu encore une fois de plus réfléchir à cela lorsque nous avons lu les versets 1 au verset 10,
malgré la violence du jugement et de ses manifestations,
donc il y avait l'épée, il y avait la famine, il y a eu du cannibalisme,
il y a eu beaucoup de choses très difficiles,
Dieu avait quand même décidé d'épargner une partie du peuple.
Il avait décidé d'épargner une partie du peuple qui allait être captif,
une partie qui allait être captive ou dispersée parmi les nations,
en plus d'un très faible reste qui allait rester sur la terre d'Israël,
mais c'était un très faible reste, c'était la population la plus pauvre qui avait été laissée,
mais tout le reste de la population soit avait été dispersée dans les nations,
soit avait été faite captive.
Et donc la dernière fois, le cœur du dernier message,
quand nous avions médité sur ces versets 8 à 10,
c'était de comprendre comment Dieu avait épargné un reste,
et pour quel dessein, et donc je mets dessein en pluriel,
pour quel dessein il avait épargné un reste.
Et donc, on avait vu que, sur la première partie,
on avait vu que, quand on parlait de comment il avait épargné le reste,
c'est qu'il y avait un reste qui allait être épargné de la famine, de l'épée, de la mort,
et ce reste allait être dispersé parmi les nations.
Et donc ça, ce sont des choses que Dieu avait annoncées,
sept siècles avant, lorsque Moïse établissait l'alliance avec Israël,
et si jamais cette alliance n'était pas respectée par Israël,
tous ces jugements étaient promis,
et justement la dispersion parmi les nations,
ou la captivité parmi les nations.
Donc c'est la première partie, dernièrement, que nous avions vue,
qui se concentrait notamment sur le verset 8.
Et dans la seconde partie,
quand nous parlons de quel dessein,
donc là encore je l'ai dit, dessein en pluriel,
le but était,
et donc quand nous avons vu
quels étaient les desseins pour lesquels
Dieu était en train d'épargner un reste,
on voyait que le but était que de là où ils étaient,
ils se souviennent de Dieu,
ils réalisent le mal qu'ils avaient fait,
et qu'ils avaient conduits à cette situation,
qu'ils se repentent,
qu'ils soient restaurés par Dieu,
des années plus tard,
en étant non seulement ramenés sur la terre de leurs ancêtres,
pour la grande majorité, pour une partie,
mais qu'ils soient aussi ramenés dans leur relation avec Dieu,
afin que le but initial pour lequel Dieu les avait suscités soit accompli.
Et le but initial que Israël n'avait pas compris,
c'était le fait qu'au travers de la loi,
ils comprendraient le besoin du Sauveur.
Et qu'au travers de cette compréhension,
en étant lumière des nations,
ils allaient faire comprendre aux nations aussi,
pourquoi tous les efforts des nations
pour pouvoir obtenir la grâce de Dieu étaient vains,
s'ils ne se tournaient pas vers le Dieu d'Israël.
C'était ce but initial,
mais Israël avait échoué,
et Israël s'était détourné en adorant des idoles et autres.
Et donc, pour nous aujourd'hui,
le cœur de notre message,
donc je peux dire la vérité centrale,
ce sera de voir comment,
donc les premiers points,
je vais faire un récapitulatif,
parce qu'il y avait quatre dessins qui étaient,
quatre dessins qui étaient,
sur lesquels nous avions médité.
Nous avions médité sur les deux premiers dessins
que je vais rappeler.
Et là, nous verrons les deux derniers dessins
de pourquoi Dieu avait épargné ce reste.
Mais nous allons voir aujourd'hui
que sur les deux derniers points,
Dieu nous montre comment la repentance,
selon Dieu, porte du fruit.
et comment Dieu est glorifié
au travers de la repentance.
Et nous devons nous souvenir
que Dieu est glorifié,
Dieu était glorifié aussi bien
dans la ruine d'Israël
que dans la restauration
qu'il était en train d'annoncer.
Donc, pour rappeler déjà
sur les premiers dessins que nous avons vus,
en réfléchissant pour quels dessins
Dieu les avait épargnés,
nous avons vu que le premier dessin
était de rappeler la bonté de Dieu.
Le premier dessin était de rappeler
un moment que Dieu
ne détruisait pas entièrement
Israël,
comme, et je l'ai dit aussi pour nous,
c'est le Dieu qui ne nous punit
jamais à la hauteur
de ce que nous méritons.
Israël, par rapport à ce que
Israël méritait,
Dieu n'a même pas exécuté
ses jugements à la hauteur
de ce que Israël méritait.
Là, nous voyons même la bonté de Dieu
dans le fait qu'il épargne
un reste du peuple.
Donc, nous voyons que Dieu
exerce sa miséricorde
et Dieu espère qu'au travers
du jugement qui est exercé,
cela les amène à la repentance
et à la sagesse nécessaire.
Et donc, nous avions vu dans le premier dessin
de Dieu, c'était de montrer un moment
que Dieu résiste aux orgueilleux,
mais il fait grâce aux hommes.
Et certaines épreuves,
là pour Israël,
ont été une porte pour leur salut,
pour leur restauration,
tout comme, même pour nous,
certaines épreuves que Dieu a permis
ont été des portes pour notre salut.
Donc, ça, c'était le premier dessin.
Le premier dessin, c'était de rappeler
la bonté de Dieu
qui n'avait même pas puni Israël
à la hauteur de ce qu'il méritait.
Le deuxième dessin
était qu'Israël,
qui avait oublié Dieu,
se souvienne de lui
au plus fort de leur détresse
au sein des nations
où ils étaient captifs.
Et nous avions rappelé,
en méditant sur ce deuxième dessin
de Dieu,
qui était de leur rappeler Dieu,
que la repentance
naît du souvenir de Dieu
et de l'obéissance
que nous lui devons.
Dieu fait grâce,
et cette grâce
allait trouver Israël,
comme nous le disions
la dernière fois.
Donc, c'était aussi
un début de ce jugement.
Et d'ailleurs, nous avions lu
le passage de Osée 2,
du verset 10 au verset 14,
qui nous rappelait très bien
qu'il pouvait synthétiser même
cet acte de Dieu
au travers du jugement.
Pourquoi il y avait le jugement?
Et pourquoi?
Et qu'est-ce que Dieu
était en train de faire
au travers de ce jugement?
Donc, dans Osée 2,
verset 10 à 14,
il était dit,
Et maintenant,
je découvrirai sa honte
aux yeux de ses amants,
et nul ne la délivrera
de ma main.
Je ferai cesser
toute sa joie,
ses fêtes,
ses nouvelles lunes,
ses sabbats
et toutes ses solennités.
Je ravagerai ses vignes
et ses figuiers
dont elle disait,
c'est le salaire
que m'ont donné mes amants.
Je les réduirai
en une forêt
et les bêtes des champs
les dévureront.
Je la châtirai
pour les jours
où elle encensait
les balles,
où elle se parait
de ses anneaux
et de ses colliers,
aller après ses amants
et m'oublier,
dit l'Éternel.
C'est pourquoi,
voici,
je veux la tirer
et la conduire
au désert
et je parlerai
à son cœur.
Donc,
Dieu est en train
d'utiliser le feu
de son jugement
pour amener Israël
à lui.
Dieu est en train
d'utiliser le feu
de son jugement
pour purifier
la nation d'Israël
qui s'était souillée
avec les idoles,
non seulement pour la purifier,
mais pour la restaurer
dans son cœur
avec la finalité
d'établir
une nouvelle alliance.
Une nouvelle alliance
qui sera encore plus excellente
que l'alliance
qu'Israël
n'avait pas pu respecter
la première fois.
Et là aussi,
nous avions lu ce passage
de Zacharie 12, 10,
toutes ces promesses
que Dieu fait
en promettant ce jugement
mais en promettant
cette restauration.
Et même là,
c'est l'Évangile
qui nous est dit
dans Zacharie 12, 10,
Alors je répondrai
sur la maison de David
et sur les habitants
de Jérusalem
un esprit de grâce
et de supplication.
Et ils tourneront
les regards vers moi,
celui qu'ils ont percé.
Ils pleureront sur lui
comme on pleure
sur un fils unique
et pleureront amèrement
sur lui
comme on pleure
sur un promené.
Donc, pour résumer,
le deuxième dessin
de Dieu,
lorsqu'il va,
il exécute son jugement
mais qu'il épargne
une partie
du peuple,
c'était pour que le peuple
se souvienne de lui,
pour que le peuple
se souvienne que
Dieu voulait
leur rappeler
un moment
qu'il ne les rejetait
pas entièrement
mais qu'il allait
même les restaurer
et même les restaurer
à quelque chose
de plus grand encore.
Ils avaient échoué
dans la première alliance.
Ça aurait dû s'arrêter là
mais Dieu ne s'est pas arrêté là.
Dieu exerce sa miséricorde
en établissant
une nouvelle alliance
encore plus excellente
et même encore plus meilleure
que la première alliance
qu'ils n'avaient pas pu respecter.
Le troisième dessin
sur lequel nous méditerons
aujourd'hui
un des
troisième et quatrième
mais le troisième dessin
sur lequel nous allons méditer
aujourd'hui
est exposé
dans la seconde partie
du verset 9.
Ils se prendront
eux-mêmes en dégoût
à cause des infamies
qu'ils ont commises
à cause de toutes
leurs abominations.
Bien que Dieu
ait été attristé
par leur conduite,
le fait qu'ils puissent
ressentir du dégoût
pour eux
et leur péché
et se repentir
était une preuve
que Dieu
ne les rejetait pas.
Nous devons nous souvenir
chaque fois que tu as
l'occasion
de te repentir
tu dois voir
que la repentance
est une preuve
de l'amour de Dieu
envers toi.
Sans repentance
il n'y a point de pardon
il n'y a point de délivrance
à venir.
Quelques points
sur lesquels
nous pouvons méditer
à partir
sur ce troisième dessin
le premier point
que nous pourrons voir
attaché à ce premier dessin
c'est que
la clé
d'une vraie repentance
!
Selon Dieu
c'est pas ma faute
alors
oui
la clé
d'une vraie repentance
selon Dieu
est de nous amener
à voir
l'abomination
du péché
lorsque Dieu
est en train
d'exécuter
ses jugements
sur Israël
sont terribles
mais qu'est-ce que
Israël doit comprendre
c'était l'abomination
de l'idolâtrie
qu'ils avaient commise
ils avaient vu cela
comme étant quelque chose
peut-être de normal
ou de pas si
agressif
puisque même
dans certains principes
ils se disaient
qu'ils ne rejetaient pas Dieu
c'est-à-dire
ils ajoutaient juste
d'autres dieux
à ce Dieu
mais Dieu
est un Dieu jaloux
dans le bon sens
du terme
parce qu'il n'y a rien
qui puisse être comparé
à Dieu
et à cause de cela
Dieu ne pouvait supporter
les idoles
qu'ils avaient
au milieu du peuple
donc la première chose
quand Dieu
dit
au verset 9
ils se prendront
eux-mêmes en dégoût
à cause des infamies
qu'ils ont commises
la première chose
que nous devons comprendre
c'est que
Dieu voulait créer en eux
une vraie repentance
qui nous amène à voir
l'abomination du péché
le péché n'est pas
quelque chose
d'innocent
le péché n'est pas
quelque chose
d'excusable
parce que nous allons
souvent trouver
une innocence au péché
pour justifier
on va trouver
beaucoup d'excuses
pour justifier le péché
on va aussi trouver
beaucoup de plaisir
à un moment
pour justifier le péché
non
le péché est une abomination
qui non seulement
souille notre être
mais aussi
tout ce que nous pouvons
accomplir
c'est ce que Dieu
était en train de faire ressortir
il était en train de faire ressortir
que malgré les sacrifices
qu'Israël avait fait
ils n'avaient pas compris
que le problème de Dieu
n'était pas que les sacrifices
soient faits
c'était déjà l'attitude du cœur
le fait que le cœur
ne soit pas tourné
selon Deutéronome 6-5
faisait que
tous les sacrifices
qu'Israël pouvait faire
étaient vains devant Dieu
et donc Dieu
était en train de leur montrer
que le péché
qu'ils avaient commis
non seulement
souillait
ce qu'ils avaient accompli
mais souillait déjà
ce qui pouvait être
à l'intérieur
le péché
souille la conscience
et nous amène
à un dégoût
de nous-mêmes
personne ne peut connaître
la paix intérieure
malgré toutes les apparences
qu'il peut se donner
lorsqu'il est en train
de pécher
même lorsqu'on va avoir
une conscience
cautérisée
c'est à dire que
même quand on a tellement
péché qu'à un moment
on trouve des justifications
on ne veut pas reconnaître
que ce qu'on a fait
n'est pas juste
même lorsqu'on va avoir
un cœur qui est cautérisé
donc qui devient insensible
au péché
et ses manifestations
nous allons toujours
être troublés
dans notre conscience
et c'est intéressant
de voir aussi
que souvent des personnes
vont vous dire
à un moment
qu'eux ils se sentent en paix
ils n'ont pas de problème
c'est vrai que
le non-croyant
celui qui ne connaît pas Dieu
qui n'a pas un cœur
régénéré
ne va pas toujours réaliser
ce que peut être le péché
mais à un moment
il est conscient
du mal qui produit
au travers du péché
et on peut essayer
de faire tout ce qu'on peut
tout ce qu'on peut
pour enlever
pour calmer notre conscience
tant qu'on ne vient pas à Dieu
à travers de la repentance
le péché sera toujours vivace
malgré tout ce qu'on peut mettre dessus
un cœur non-repentant
trouvera normal de péché
et de se souiller
et encouragera même
d'autres à le faire de même
et d'ailleurs
quelles vont être les excuses
qui sommes-nous pour juger
ça c'est dans notre génération
qui es-tu pour juger
qui sommes-nous pour juger
même quand nous voyons
le mal qui est manifesté
on arrive même
à un point
où on est en train
de commencer
à vouloir
dire un moment
qui sommes-nous pour juger
des actes de pédophilie
le fait que quelqu'un
de 50 ans
soit avec une fille
de 15 ans
qui sommes-nous pour juger
c'est
voilà
donc le cœur non-repentant
trouvera normal de péché
de se souiller
mais celui
en qui Dieu produit
la repentance
réalisera
que le péché
et ses manifestations
le péché
est une abomination
aux yeux de Dieu
il sera attristé
d'avoir trahi Dieu
d'avoir blessé
les hommes
avec les fruits
et les conséquences
des péchés commis
c'est très important
la dernière fois
quand nous avions
médité sur
une partie
de la repentance
nous avions rappelé
que le principe
de la repentance
c'est d'abord
de réaliser
que nous avons péché
contre Dieu
et ensuite
que nous avons péché
contre l'homme
mais souvent
l'homme va se focaliser
sur le fait
qu'il ait fait le mal
à l'autre
lorsque il est exposé
et donc
nous sommes toujours
sur la clé
d'une vraie repentance
la vraie repentance
selon Dieu
c'est une repentance
à salut
dont on ne se repend jamais
dont on ne revient jamais
en arrière
le chrétien
se repend de ses péchés
au moment de sa conversion
mais il se repend aussi
en tant que croyant
de ses péchés au quotidien
et pourquoi nous nous repentons
afin de vivre
et de préserver
l'oeuvre du Saint-Esprit
au travers de la joie
la paix
et les autres fruits
que l'Esprit donne
et
mais un coeur non régénéré
un coeur non sanctifié
ne voit pas
le péché
comme une abomination
et la tristesse
qu'il peut éprouver
face au péché
est plutôt due
au fait d'être exposé
c'est pour ça que je disais
là maintenant
pour celui
la tristesse
selon l'homme
on ne va pas être
triste
d'avoir d'abord
blessé
blessé c'est une expression
parce que
Dieu ne peut pas être
touché par ces choses
mais nous allons
nous allons être tristes
d'avoir
d'avoir trahi Dieu
comme j'avais pris
ce sens là
d'avoir trahi Dieu
et ensuite nous voyons
les conséquences
pour les hommes
mais la tristesse
selon le monde
la repentance
c'est d'avoir une repentance
qui va être faite
on va éprouver
de la tristesse
parce qu'on est exposé
par rapport à notre péché
on va éprouver
de la tristesse
parce qu'on a été
blessé dans son orgueil
parce qu'à un moment
on voulait donner une image
selon l'image
qu'on pouvait se donner
devant les autres
lorsque cette image
est déformée
à cause du péché
on va demander pardon
afin que les gens
puissent nous revoir
comme nous étions
si parfaits
ou bien
on va à un moment
avoir de la tristesse
qu'on va éprouver
face au péché
parce qu'on n'a pas pu
assouvir les plaisirs
de la chair
regardons dans le monde
d'hypocrisie
à un moment
de plusieurs patrons
d'entreprises
qui lorsque le scandale
est exposé
par rapport à un produit
c'est là
ils vont demander pardon
ils savaient le scandale
mais comme là maintenant
il s'agit de perdre de l'argent
ils vont pleurer devant
ils vont être tristes
mais ils ne sont pas tristes
ils sont tristes
à cause du fait
qu'ils sont exposés
et quand nous avons
ce genre de tristesse
qui est basé
sur le fait
qu'on est exposé
on est blessé
dans son orgueil
ou on n'a pas pu
assouvir
les plaisirs
de la chair
c'est une tristesse
qui conduit
à la honte
c'est une tristesse
qui conduit
à la culpabilité
c'est une tristesse
qui conduit
à l'apitoillement
sur soi
c'est une tristesse
qui conduit
au manque d'estime
de soi
c'est une tristesse
qui conduit
même à la dépression
et c'est une tristesse
qui peut même conduire
à une mort directe
parce que des personnes
vont même se suicider
un moment
ou même à la mort éternelle
plus tard
notre estime de soi
doit être centré
sur Christ
et d'ailleurs
je vous rappelle
pour ceux qui n'ont pas
encore eu l'occasion
pensez à réécouter
la série de messages
d'enseignements
qui sont faits
sur la crainte
de Dieu
et la crainte
quelle doit être
la crainte de Dieu
et qu'est-ce que peut être
la crainte de l'homme
et c'est très important
aussi pour nous
ça nous permet aussi
de comprendre
où nous devons
centrer notre estime
de soi
Dieu résiste
aux orgueilleux
mais il fait grâce
aux humbles
donc
la clé
d'une vraie repentance
selon Dieu
lorsque
elle est exprimée
ça va nous conduire
à une joie
d'expérimenter
le pardon
de Dieu
et nous allons éviter
l'endurcissement
du coeur
un autre aspect
toujours attaché
à ce troisième dessin
donc le premier aspect
attaché à ce dessin
c'était la clé
d'une vraie repentance
selon Dieu
qui nous amène
à voir
l'abomination
du péché
le deuxième point
par rapport
à ce troisième dessin
c'est de voir
à un moment
qui nous avons
et c'est ce que nous avions
dit la dernière fois
le fait
de ne pas
le fait que Israël
n'ait pas respecté
le commandement
de Deutéronome
6-5
a ouvert la porte
non seulement
à l'idolâtrie
mais aussi à de nombreux
autres péchés
donc nous voyons
que de nombreux mots
donc des dommages
ou des préjudices
si on peut le dire
accompagner les manifestations
de ces péchés
d'idolâtrie
pour Israël
il y a eu beaucoup
de péchés
qui sont rentrés
parce qu'ils n'ont pas
respecté Deutéronome
6-5
l'idolâtrie
pratiquée par Israël
avait ouvert la porte
à plusieurs autres péchés
ils ont pratiqué
la prostitution sacrée
le meurtre
donc à un moment
ils offraient un sacrifice
lors des enfants
ils ont pratiqué
plusieurs autres péchés
et donc nous pouvons
voir un moment
et c'est valable
ce qui est valable
qui a été valable
pour Israël
l'est aussi valable
pour nos sociétés
c'est ce que nous avons dit
le non-respect
de Deutéronome 6-5
qui signifie donc
le rejet
et l'oubli de Dieu
au sein de la vie
de quelqu'un
ou d'une nation
ouvre la porte
à une multitude
de péchés
je vais rappeler
ce que j'avais dit
j'avais partagé
lors de la prédication
sur la fin
du chapitre 5
je crois
c'était
vers le 13 juillet
je rappelle ce passage
qui parlait justement
de ce point
où lorsque nous
sommes en train
de négliger
Deutéronome 6-5
qui est d'aimer
l'éternel
de tout notre coeur
de toute notre âme
de toute notre force
si nous ne sommes pas
en train de le faire
nous ouvrons une porte
nous ouvrons la porte
à une multitude
d'autres péchés
Paul nous rappelle
dans 1 Corinthiens 10
donc le passage
qu'il y a dans 1 Corinthiens 10
que c'est un passage
qui doit nous servir
d'exemple
sur les conséquences
du péché d'idolâtrie
lorsque nous détournons
notre affection de Dieu
comme Israël l'a fait
pour la tourner
vers des idoles
qu'elles soient physiques
ou non
nous ouvrons la porte
à une multitude
de péchés dans nos vies
lorsque nous nous engageons
lorsque nous n'engageons
pas tout notre être
à aimer Dieu
les fruits que porte
notre coeur
auront pour conséquence
non seulement
de nous faire souffrir
mais aussi de faire souffrir
ce que Dieu place
sur notre chemin
regardons ce que causent
les mauvaises pensées
envers notre prochain
les soupçons du mal
les haines
les rancunes
regardons les meurtres
d'individus
ou d'état
par cupidité
par jalousie
par orgueil
regardons les adultères
qui détruisent
des familles
les impudicités
qui dérèglent
la vision de l'homme
et la femme
en plus d'autres conséquences
comme les avortements
les naissances
non désirées
les maladies sexuelles
et ainsi de suite
regardons les vols
et toutes les injustices
qui les accompagnent
les faux témoignages
qui sont légions
tout cela
les calomnies
qui détruisent
des vies
et des réputations
tout cela
provient de cœurs
qui se sont détournés
de Dieu
dès que nous sommes
en train de rejeter
Deutéronome 6.5
nous ouvrons la porte
au fait que ces choses
soient présentes
et normales dans nos vies
et les personnes
qui pratiquent ces choses
vont même trouver normal
et même moral
de pratiquer ces péchés
malgré les conséquences
néfastes
qui se produisent
dans leur vie
et qui produisent
même dans la vie
des autres
et donc
nous voyons
dans le
le
troisième point
de ce troisième dessin
le troisième dessin
c'était que Dieu provoque
dans le cœur d'Israël
qu'est-ce qu'il dit
Ils se prendront
eux-mêmes en dégoût
à cause des infamies
qu'ils ont cohés
la détestation
du péché
!
s'accompagnera
toujours du dégoût
de ce que nous pouvons être
Le péché
s'accompagne
d'une souillou morale
qui ne peut être
enlevée par nos efforts
enlevée par nos sacrifices
Le péché
c'est une tâche
indélébile
que seule la croix
de Christ
peut effacer
La colère divine
due à nos péchés
ne peut être expiée
que par le sang
du Christ
Et
quel que soit
ce qu'on peut dire
à un moment
et voilà pourquoi
la Bible va être très claire
quand elle va nous dire
à un moment
le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
rappelle à un moment
qu'il est le chemin
la vérité et la vie
Quelles que soient
les religions des hommes
tous les efforts
qui sont faits
dans les religions
c'est de produire
des efforts
à cause des péchés
présents dans la vie
pour pouvoir
calmer les consciences
et on est toujours
et on est toujours obligé
de faire plus d'efforts
plus d'efforts
pour trouver cette paix
mais la Bible
nous rappelle un moment
que la seule façon
pour nous
de pouvoir
connaître
la paix
parce que le péché
est une tâche
indélébile
il n'y a que le sang
de Christ
qui peut l'effacer
la détestation du péché
quand la repentance
quand nous réalisons
que le péché
est une abomination
la détestation du péché
s'accompagnera
toujours du dégoût
de ce que nous pouvons être
le manque de repentance
si tu es un croyant
et que tu es en train
d'être
touché par un péché
et que tu es en train
de refuser
de te repentir
tu vas produire
ce dégoût en toi
et d'ailleurs
qu'est-ce que tu vas produire
tu vas produire
une lutte intense
dans ton coeur
et c'est une lutte
qui va trouver sa fin
que lorsque tu accepteras
de venir à la croix du Christ
c'est une lutte
qui va connaître sa fin
que lorsque nous allons
reconnaître
l'horreur du péché
quel qu'il soit
c'est très important
parce que nous essayons
toujours un moment
quand nous sommes
affectés par le péché
nous essayons toujours
même de trouver
des tailles au péché
il y a des péchés
qui sont plus petits
ce n'est pas
d'ailleurs on va dire
à un moment
tout le monde ment
dans ce monde
donc voilà pourquoi
je peux mentir
je trouve normal
de mentir
le mensonge
est un péché
qui te conduira
en enfer
aussi bien
que l'impudicité
et donc
lorsque nous
sommes en train
de résister
à la repentance
tout ce que nous allons
produire
c'est de laisser
une souillure morale
une souillure
qui va
entacher notre coeur
qui va nous empêcher
de connaître la paix
mais cette paix
nous allons la reconnaître
que si nous venons
à la croix
si nous reconnaissons
l'horreur du péché
si nous ne rejetons
la faute sur quiconque
que sur nous-mêmes
nous ne trouvons
aucune excuse
nous avons péché
et nous ne sommes pas
en train d'associer
d'autres à notre péché
et nous supplions
Dieu au travers
de notre souverain
sacrificateur parfait
pour obtenir sa grâce
et son pardon
et là pour ça
je vous invite
à relire
le psaume 51
et vous verrez
un moment
que le psalmiste
ce sont toutes ces étapes
qu'il suit
un moment
de constater un moment
l'horreur du péché
de ne pas se trouver
d'excuses vis-à-vis du péché
et de venir auprès du Seigneur
pour trouver le pardon
et alors
lorsque nous sommes
en train de faire cela
parce que
une des choses
quand je méditais là-dessus
c'était souvent
d'entendre
beaucoup de personnes
qui vont dire
un moment
mais comment nous pouvons savoir
quand nous confessons
notre péché
et que nous savons
que nous sommes pardonnés
mais la vérité
c'est que
quand nous sommes
en train de respecter
ce qui est dit
dans ce que je viens de dire
lorsque nous sommes
en train de reconnaître
l'horreur du péché
nous constatons
que ce que nous avons fait
est une abomination
que nous ne trouvons pas
d'excuses
et que nous venons
avec humilité
au pied du Seigneur
et que nous demandons
pardon
alors nous savons
que nous allons être pardonnés
Miché 7
verset 18 à 20
quel Dieu
est semblable à toi
qui pardonne l'iniquité
qui oublie les péchés
du reste de ton héritage
il ne garde pas sa colère
à toujours
car il prend plaisir
à la miséricorde
il aura encore
compassion de nous
il mettra sous ses pieds
nos iniquités
tu jetteras
au fond de la mer
tous leurs péchés
tu témoigneras
de la fidélité
à Jacob
de la bonté
à Abraham
comme tu l'as juré
à nos pères
au jour d'autrefois
donc en conclusion
pour ce troisième dessin
donc ce troisième dessin
qui était
d'amener Israël
à avoir un dégoût
du péché
à comprendre
un moment
que le péché
avait été une abomination
et qu'ils aient un dégoût
voilà pourquoi
Dieu permettait
à ce reste
ce reste de se repentir
mais que ce reste
réalise un moment
que ce péché
avait été une abomination
et qu'ils soient
en dégoût
de ce péché
Dieu rappelle un moment
qui produisait cela
afin que
cette alliance excellente
puisse être produite
Israël allait se souvenir
de ce qu'ils avaient fait
dans le passé
et ils n'allaient pas
trouver une quelconque gloire
ils allaient reconnaître
qu'ils avaient péché
qu'ils allaient être confus
ils allaient demander
pardon à Dieu
c'était le but
de ce troisième dessin
quand il épargne le reste
et enfin
le quatrième dessin
est exposé
au verset 10
et ils sauront
que je suis l'éternel
et que ce n'est pas en vain
que je les ai menacés
de leur envoyer
tous ces mots
Dieu souligne
une fois de plus
et ça nous l'avons déjà vu
dans Ézéchiel
plusieurs fois
nous voyons au moment
que chaque fois
que le Seigneur
est en train d'annoncer
ses jugements
au travers d'Ézéchiel
il est en train
de préciser un moment
ainsi parle l'éternel
ils sauront
que je suis l'éternel
Dieu souligne
une fois de plus
qu'en vivant
le jugement
de Dieu
Israël allait savoir
que Dieu
était vrai
dans ce qu'il pouvait dire
dans ce qu'il pouvait faire
un moment
à cause du péché
ils avaient oublié Dieu
ils avaient oublié ce Dieu
qu'ils avaient porté
qu'ils avaient gardé
pendant plus de 7 siècles
mais une des choses
qui allaient être rappelées
à eux
au travers de ce jugement
c'est qu'ils allaient savoir
que l'éternel était vivant
dans ce qu'ils pouvaient dire
dans ce qu'ils pouvaient faire
c'était pas une menace vaine
d'ailleurs
le problème qu'il y avait
quand Ézéchiel
est en train d'annoncer
ses jugements
c'est que beaucoup
n'étaient pas convaincus
que cela allait arriver
ils étaient sûrs
donc dans le contexte géopolitique
au moment que l'Égypte
allait renverser Babylone
et que le royaume de Juda
allait être délivré
ils étaient sûrs
qu'ils allaient même
Babylone allait être détruite
et qu'ils allaient revenir
dans leur terre
même au moment
Jérémie leur dit
non
vous allez rester à Babylone
Ézéchiel leur dit
non
vous allez rester à Babylone
et pourquoi ?
c'était pour qu'ils sachent
que ce n'était pas
une menace vaine
mais que c'était bien
une résolution
qui était arrêtée
de la part de Dieu
à cause de leur péché
ce n'était pas
le fruit du hasard
mais bien une décision
qui était fondée
qui trouvait ses racines
au moment de l'alliance
établie avec le peuple
d'Israël
sept siècles avant
donc ce quatrième dessin
c'était qu'ils sachent
que c'était l'éternel
et que ce n'était pas en vain
qu'ils les avaient menacés
donc quelques points aussi
que nous pouvons voir
par rapport à ce quatrième dessin
le premier point
c'est que Dieu
allait faire connaître à Israël
qu'il était Seigneur
aussi bien
dans la ruine
qu'ils allaient vivre
que dans leur repentance
c'est important de voir
que Dieu annonce
le jugement
mais il annonce aussi
que parmi ce reste
qu'il va épargner
ce reste va se repentir
et ce reste va revenir au Seigneur
donc Dieu allait leur faire connaître
qu'il était Seigneur
aussi bien dans la ruine
qu'ils vivraient
que dans leur repentance
les punitions
les jugements de Dieu
étaient des opportunités
donc ces jugements
ces punitions
étaient des opportunités
pour les amener à la repentance
et c'est même valable aussi pour nous
nous devons voir à un moment
que ces punitions
ces jugements de Dieu
sont aussi des opportunités
pour nous amener à la repentance
parce que
quand Dieu exerce son amour
et sa miséricorde
ça a été le cas d'Israël
Dieu a exercé son amour
et sa miséricorde
donc pour vous donner le cycle
je vous avais rappelé le cycle
à un moment
Dieu lève des hommes
des dirigeants fidèles à lui
qui conduisent le peuple
dans la crainte de l'éternel
quand ces hommes meurent
le peuple se détourne de Dieu
et ensuite
des nations étrangères
les envahissent
et les soumettent en esclavage
Dieu lève un libérateur
ce libérateur les libère
il vit
il craigne Dieu
tout le temps de la vie
de ce libérateur
ou de ce roi
dès qu'il meurt
il se détourne
donc ça c'était à peu près le cycle
et donc
pendant sept siècles
depuis l'alliance
établie avec Moïse
jusqu'à cette période
d'Ézéchiel
on va voir un moment
que Dieu a exercé
beaucoup de son amour
et de sa miséricorde
ce qui fait que
ses jugements étaient retardés
retardés
et Israël a choisi
de s'endurcir
et de mépriser
la patience du Seigneur
je risque de finir
Israël a choisi
de s'endurcir
de mépriser
la patience du Seigneur
ils l'ont fait
pendant des siècles
et ce que nous avions dit aussi
en méditant aussi là dessus
c'est que c'est encore le cas
dans nos générations actuelles
parce que le jugement de Dieu
tarde à venir
le jugement de Dieu
et donc
beaucoup
sont en train
de
beaucoup seront surpris
à cause de l'endurcissement
de leur cœur
donc voilà
le Seigneur
était aussi bien glorifié
dans la ruine
que dans cette repentance
l'autre point
attaché à ce quatrième dessin
c'est que dans leur repentance
ils reconnaîtraient
que Dieu
avait été juste
dans ces jugements
c'est important
de voir
sur ces points
tous les points
qui ont été
édictés
quand on parlait
de ces dessins
qui étaient attachés
les dessins
c'était que
Israël se souvienne
de l'éternel
Israël réalise
qu'ils avaient péché
Israël est en dégoût
le fait qu'ils avaient péché
mais Israël aussi
reconnaît
c'est un moment
que Dieu
avait été juste
dans ces jugements
donc dans leur repentance
ils reconnaîtraient
que Dieu
avait été juste
dans ces jugements
que la parole de Dieu
était vraie
notamment dans les paroles
d'avertissement
qu'il avait énoncées
par les prophètes
depuis les siècles
de patience
et ces paroles
allaient confirmer
que Dieu
était bien
le Dieu souverain
le Dieu éternel
le Dieu juste
mais aussi
le Dieu fidèle
et miséricordieux
en conclusion
nous voyons
donc
pourquoi Dieu
était en train
d'épargner un reste
parce que c'était
la centralité
des versets
8 à 10
quand il dit
à un moment
j'épargnerai ce reste
et je l'amènerai
je briserai son cœur
qui avait été adulté
à fidèle
et il va le ramener
à lui
Dieu
dans ses jugements
épargne ce reste
afin que celui-ci
se souvienne
de l'éternel
que ce reste
se repente
et que dans sa contrition
il reconnaisse
que Dieu
avait été juste
mais miséricordieux
en les épargnant
et que ses grandes
compassions
n'étaient pas encore
arrivées à leur terme
envers Israël
c'est aussi ça
qui est réconfortant
quand nous lisons
Ézéchiel 6
même quand nous lisons
souvent le livre
d'Ézéchiel
beaucoup de personnes
se focalisent
sur les jugements
de Dieu
qui sont faits
sur Israël
et les nations
mais ils n'arrivent pas
à voir comment
les compassions
de Dieu
ressortent grandement
aussi bien envers
Israël
qu'envers ses nations
et donc
nous pouvons voir
l'exhaustement
de ce que je vous ai dit
voilà un passage
qui résume
parfaitement
tout ce que nous avons dit
sur ces versets
8 à 10
et qui va se trouver
dans la prière
que Daniel
va faire
donc Daniel 9
du verset 1
au verset 9
je vais lire une partie
je vais lire
oui cette partie
du verset 1
au verset 9
donc lorsque Daniel
est en train
de faire cette prière
cette prière
au verset 1
il dit
la première année
de Darius
fils d'Assyrus
de la race des Mèdes
lequel était devenu
roi du royaume
des Chaldéens
donc là
ce passage
c'est 70 ans
après
le jugement
c'est 70 ans
après le jugement
ça correspond
à la première année
Darius
dans le terme
au niveau
des Acheminides
donc la dynastie
Acheminides
les Perses
il se désignait
souvent sous le nom
de Darius
comment on va dire
pharaon
donc vous allez voir
Darius 1
Darius 3
donc souvent le terme
là on parle de Cyrus
on parle de Cyrus
mais il est désigné
sous le nom de Darius
et donc
Daniel est en train
de faire cette intercession
70 ans
après ce que Dieu
est en train de dire
au travers
de la parole
et ça doit nous réconforter
sous la souveraineté
de notre Dieu
sous la grandeur
c'est étonnant
de voir
comment
on voit ce fil rouge
au travers
des propos de Jérémie
d'Ézéchiel
qui arrivent même
70 ans plus tard
à leur accomplissement
avec Daniel
donc je lis le passage
Daniel
la première année
de Darius
fils d'Assyrus
de la race des Med
lequel était devenu
roi du royaume
des Chaldéens
la première année
de son règne
moi Daniel
je vis par les livres
qu'il devait s'écouler
70 ans
pour les ruines
de Jérusalem
d'après le nombre
des années
dont l'Éternel
avait parlé
à Jérémie le prophète
je tournais ma face
vers le Seigneur Dieu
afin de recourir
à la prière
et aux supplications
en jeûnant
et en prenant
le sac et la cendre
je priais l'Éternel
mon Dieu
et je lui fis
cette confession
Seigneur
Dieu
grand et redoutable
toi qui garde
ton alliance
et qui fais miséricorde
à ceux qui t'aiment
et qui observent
tes commandements
nous avons péché
nous avons commis
l'iniquité
nous avons été
méchants et rebelles
nous nous sommes détournés
de tes commandements
et de tes ordonnances
nous n'avons pas
écouté tes serviteurs
les prophètes
qui ont parlé
en ton nom
à nos rois
à nos chefs
à nos pères
et à tout le peuple
du pays
à toi Seigneur
et la justice
et à nous
la confusion de face
en ce jour
aux hommes du Juda
aux habitants
de Jérusalem
et à tout Israël
à ceux qui sont prêts
et à ceux qui sont loin
dans tous les pays
où tu les as chassés
à cause des infidélités
dont ils se sont rendus
coupables envers toi
Seigneur
à nous la confusion
de face
à nos rois
à nos chefs
et à nos pères
parce que nous avons
péché contre toi
auprès du Seigneur
notre Dieu
la miséricorde
et le pardon
car nous avons été
rebelles envers lui
C'est étonnant
de voir comment
tout ce que Dieu
prophétise
par Ézéchiel
quand nous lisons
par exemple
le but pour lequel
il va épargner ce reste
rien que cette prière
de Daniel
trouve l'accomplissement
de tout ce que Dieu a dit
Daniel se souvient
de ce que Dieu a dit
le principe
de ce souvenir
ils se souviendront
de l'éternel
Daniel se souvient
de la parole
de l'éternel
qui a été dite
par Jérémie
il se souvient
de ces 70 années
qui ont été prononcées
Daniel intercède
parce que c'est ce que
aussi le Seigneur avait dit
ils se tourneront
vers moi
ils demanderont pardon
Daniel recourt
à la prière
aux supplications
il prend même le jeûne
et il confesse
les péchés
et quand il confesse
il rappelle
que Dieu
est fidèle
dans son alliance
le problème
n'avait pas été Dieu
avait été Israël
au moment où le jugement
peut arriver
Israël pouvait trouver
Dieu injuste
envers eux
mais ils étaient en train
d'avoir la mémoire courte
Dieu avait été patient
pendant plusieurs siècles
et lorsque Daniel
est en train
de faire la prière
il ne cherche pas
d'excuses
il n'est pas en train
de dire
tu nous as abandonnés
non
nous avons péché
nous avons commis
l'iniquité
il demande même pardon
même pour lui
et donc à l'époque
Daniel
là il est déjà
il est à peu près
dans ses 80 ans
parce qu'il a été déporté
entre ses 12 et 15 ans
et là
ça fait plus de 70 ans
et donc
c'est déjà
quelqu'un qui est
dans sa vieillesse
et qui était même
peut-être
qui était même
peut-être pas forcément
responsable de ses péchés
mais il intercède
en reconnaissant
que Dieu a été juste
dans ses jugements
parce qu'il s'était
détourné des commandements
et des ordonnances
de Dieu
et il reconnaît
un moment
que Dieu est juste
et à eux
la confusion
vous voyez
ce dégoût
de prendre ce dégoût
dégoût à cause du péché
de reconnaître
un moment
qu'ils sont confus
qu'ils ne méritent pas
cette grâce de Dieu
et pourtant
eux qui ne méritent pas
cette grâce de Dieu
auprès de notre Dieu
la miséricorde
le pardon
car nous avons été
rebelles envers lui
eux qui ne méritaient pas
cette miséricorde
il est en train
de rappeler un moment
qu'il est compassion
de Dieu
il le dit même
à la suite
je peux vous inviter
à continuer à lire
cette prière
il dit un moment
car tes compassions
ne sont pas arrivées
tes grandes compassions
à leur terme
l'importance
de la repentance
c'est de nous rappeler
que le péché
est une abomination
aux yeux de Dieu
l'importance
de la repentance
c'est de nous rappeler
pour nous croyants
que nous avons trahi Dieu
dans ce que nous connaissons
de juste
parce que nous servons
un Dieu qui est saint
mais nous reconnaissons aussi
que ce Dieu
qui est saint
ce Dieu qui est juste
est un Dieu
puissamment miséricordieux
un Dieu fidèle
pour nous pardonner
nos péchés